Deirdre está trabajando con una función
que contiene los siguientes puntos:
aquí están los valores de "x"
y aquí los valores de "y"
y nos preguntan,
¿esta función es lineal o no lineal?
Podemos reconocer una función lineal
porque para cada cambio de "x",
vamos a obtener un incremento igual en "y",
cada vez que "x" cambia en una unidad
"y" cambia en 3 unidades o en 5 unidades
pero el cambio en "y" es siempre el mismo
si así sucede en una función podemos saber
que estamos tratando con una función lineal
por ejemplo vemos que aquí los valores de "x"
cambian en una unidad cada vez
y vamos a ver si los cambios en
"y" son siempre iguales
si no son iguales,
entonces esta función no es lineal
y lo podemos mostrar haciendo la gráfica.
Ahora si los cambios en "x"
son de diferentes valores
por ejemplo,
si tenemos 1, luego 2 y luego 4,
lo que tenemos que hacer entonces es,
dividir el cambio en "y",
entre el cambio en "x",
y siempre nos debe dar una constante...
déjenme escribir de este lado
lineal
Si la función es lineal,
entonces el cambio en "y"...
el cambio en "y",
sobre el cambio en "x"...
cambio en "x"...
será siempre constante...
siempre, constante.
En este ejemplo el cambio en "x" es siempre 1
vamos de
1 a 2, de 2 a 3, de 3 a 4 y de 4 a 5
el cambio siempre es 1
y para que esta función sea lineal
el cambio en "y" debe ser constante
vamos a tomar el cambio
y lo vamos a dividir entre 1
ok, vamos a ver
si este cambio es constante
de 11 a 14,
el cambio es 3
cuando vamos de 14 a 19,
el cambio es 5
y ya estamos viendo que no es constante,
en este punto no cambió en 3,
sino que cambió en 5
en este otro punto el cambio es 7
y por último aquí el cambio es de 9
el cambio se va incrementando,
no es un cambio constante, así que podemos saber
que esta función, no es una función lineal
y lo podemos comprobar con la gráfica
aquí voy a dibujar el eje vertical,
el eje "y"
y debemos llegar a 35
5, 10, 15, 20, 25, 30 y 35
y aquí voy a dibujar el eje "x",
obviamente la escala no va a ser igual
aquí tengo 1, 2, 3, 4 y 5.
Y empiezo a poner los puntos,
el primero es 1, 11
donde "x" es 1,
y "y" es 11
es más o menos por aquí,
en el siguiente "x" es 2,
y "y" es 14
éste está por aquí
cuando "x" es 3,
"y" es 19
"x" es 3,
y "y" es 19
y lo ponemos por aquí.
cuando "x" es 4,
"y" es 26
"x" es 4 y "y" es 26,
más o menos por aquí,
y por último "x" es 5,
y "y" es 35
"x" es 5 y "y" es 35,
este nos queda por aquí...
y vemos inmediatamente que el resultado
no es una línea recta
una función lineal produce una línea,
que se vería más o menos así,
por eso se llama función lineal
pero esto que graficamos aquí,
no es una función lineal
los cambios en "y"
se van incrementando.